quite a few months back open AI released
swarm an open- Source AI agent framework
that allows you to write super clean and
simple python code to build AI agents
and connect them together to do some
powerful things I covered it on my
channel a few months back and I was
impressed but open AI made it very clear
that swarm was experimental and meant
mostly for educational purposes not a
production ready framework but now open
aai has released their brand new agent
SDK it's built on top of swarm and still
completely free and open source but they
claim that it is now production ready
and very easy to use to build full
agentic AI apps with very few
abstractions and those seem like bold
claims to me so in this video I want to
walk through the agent SDK with you
build some powerful agents with it and
then see if it's really worth using over
all the other options that we already
have out there like Lang chain and crew
a pantic AI so here is the game plan
first I want to show you what you can do
with the agent SDK well start with a
basic example and then get into more
complex agentic systems that are pretty
powerful for how simple they are to
build then with that in mind I want to
have an honest chat with you because
open AI is claiming this is not a toy
anymore it is the real deal a production
AI agent framework is that really the
case or are other Frameworks that I
generally prefer like pantic Ai and Lane
graph still the way to go I've got a lot
of thoughts on that that I'll share at
the end but for now let's dive into
building something awesome with the
agent SDK so here we are are in the
GitHub repository for open ai's Agent
SDK I'll link to this in the description
of this video and I'll do the same for
their documentation too which is pretty
comprehensive walking you through
getting started and all the features
that they offer and The Core Concepts
for the SDK are agents handoffs guard
rails and tracing and I'm going to cover
all of these in our code examples as we
build with the agent SDK so agents
pretty basic that's giving your
instructions and tools to your llms and
then the hand hand offs this is how you
have different agents that work together
so you have specialized agents that
handle different parts of tackling a
problem very common in good Agent
architecture and handoffs are the way to
make that very easy to set up within the
agent SDK and then guard rails this is
something super important that I don't
see in Frameworks usually so having
safety checks that you can create they
can be custom they can use llms you
validate input and output for your llms
and you can stop responses from
happening if you detect hallucinations
and things like that it's pretty need
and then tracing is your way to look
into peer into your llms and agents
running checking on all the PRS and the
outputs and seeing where things are
going wrong if they do so this is very
powerful to help you debug your agents
and also monitor them in production as
well and getting started with the agent
SDK could not be simpler so over in the
documentation here just the intro
homepage tab if you scroll down you get
the installation instructions just a
single line with Pip and then they have
a very basic example of building an
agent with the SDK and this is what
we're going to be using as a starting
point so I'll help you build an agent
like this just Bare Bones and then we'll
build on top of it adding all of the
features like guard rails and handoffs
and tracing that make this SDK so
powerful so let's dive into that right
now so over in this GitHub repository
that I'll have linked to in the
description of this video we're going to
be building out an AI agent system in
six different parts using the open aai
Agent SDK so we'll start super basic
we're going to build this from scratch
together just laying the groundwork with
a version one and then we'll add in the
different features of the agent SDK that
make it so powerful like the way it
handles structured outputs adding in
tool calls agent handoffs and then
finally our guard rails and user context
management as well so a lot of awesome
different features and what we're
building together here is a travel
planner assistant it can take in
preferences from a user like you can see
on the left hand side and then we can
ask it to plan trips for us and there's
a specialized agent for managing
one for hotel reservations and another
to suggest activities for us to do and
so it's multiple agents working together
here because agents always operate much
much better when they're specialized to
something and you have many of them
working together so I can say for
example I'm planning a trip to Miami for
5 days with a budget of $2,000 and then
it'll give a general recommendation here
I can also ask it for things like give
me some Hotel recommendations it kind of
already gave me one but we'll ask it for
more specific specific recommendations
and we can have a conversation with it
and it's going to hand off to the
different agents to help us with the
different parts of planning our trip it
is super neat so there we go Hotel
recommendation a City Center Hotel this
is all mock data by the way but it takes
in our preferences make sure that we
have things like the gym and Wi-Fi
amenities and then if I ask about a
flight hopefully itd recommend an Ocean
Air flight so it's taking in preferences
handling different specialized agents
it's not a trivial agent that we're
building here we're going to be able to
do it very easily with the open AI agent
SDK so if you want to follow along and
run all this yourself you can download
this GitHub repository and then in the
readme I have instructions for setting
up everything including installing the
open a SDK and all your other python
requirements and then setting up your
EnV file as well so you can set up your
openai API key and then the llm that you
want to use I'm going to be using GPT 4
mini for everything and by the way let
me show this really quick you can run
other models with the open AI SDK
besides open AI models and so if you go
to the models page and their
documentation they instruct on how you
can set up custom clients so that for
anything that is open AI compatible like
open router or olama you can use those
providers within the SDK as well so I
just want to note that really quick but
right here just to keep things simple
I'm going to be using GPT 40 mini for my
model for everything and so over to our
first implementation here I'm developing
this in parts to make it as simple as I
possibly can for you so we're going to
start really basic here and then by the
end of this like you saw with that
travel planner agent we have something
pretty cool and so first I'm going to
import my libraries and then load in my
environment variables which to start I'm
just using the openai API key and then I
can Define my agent this is directly
from the agent SDK and so I give it a
name I give it the instructions which is
the system prompt for the agent and then
right now I have my model hardcoded I'll
use the environment variable later but
just using GPT 4al mini it is that easy
to Define the initial version of our
agent and then in the main function I'm
just calling the Run sync function for
the runner where I pass in the agent
that I want to use that we just defined
and then a user prompt write me a haikou
about recursion in programming and then
I just print out the final output that
is it it is that easy only a few lines
of code to get everything set up
initially with our framework here and so
I can go to terminal now let me zoom in
a little bit so it's easy for you to see
I'll just run the command Python and
then version one basic agent. piy and
because it's GPT 40 mini it's pretty
fast we'll get a response really quick
here this is our Hau so very basic to
start but that lays the groundwork for
us to then start to build out our travel
planner agents let's go on to version
two so now onto version two we want to
add in structured outputs and what
structured outputs are is a way to
standardize the response from En large
language model essentially forcing it to
give a Json response so that there are
specific values we can always expect it
to give like for our travel agent we
wanted to always give a recommend reced
budget and a recommended list of
activities and we can do that with what
I'm about to show you and so I have a
very similar skeleton that we saw in
version one this time we're going to
dynamically load our model from our
environment variable and then I'm going
to define the model this determines the
exact structure that our travel agent is
going to Output every single time it is
always going to give us a destination
the duration of the trip the budget its
recommended activities and then any
other notes that it has for
what it has outputed as well and we're
going to use this within our agent which
we'll Define right here so it's going to
look very similar to our agent in
version one just with a much longer set
of instructions because we're getting
more comprehensive here the model is
defined in the same way and now we say
that our output type is the travel plan
so we pass in this class that we defined
right here to instruct it exactly how to
Output our response so every single time
we can expect to have these pieces of
information so it's not random this is
is one of the ways to reduce
hallucinations with llms a lot
structured outputs are powerful and so
now within our main function I just have
a couple of queries that I'm going to
test one after the other and so we'll
Loop through each query and we'll call
our agent in the same way we did before
just passing in the agent and the user
message and then I just have some fancy
print statements here to make it look
nice in the terminal and that is it so
now we can go back over to our terminal
and this time instead of running version
one we'll do version two and so we'll
see both queries come in one after the
other first it's I'm planning a trip to
Miami and so it's something kind of
similar to what we saw in the demo and
look at that we've got the duration
budget recommended activities and notes
and then for our trip to Tokyo the exact
same thing so using structured outputs
we get a very consistent response and
that's something that you don't always
get with llms very powerful stuff the
sponsor of today's video is codo and I'm
excited to tell you about them today
because they are a free- to-use AI
coding assistant that has some unique
features to make them Stand Out versus
other AI IDE they have a big focus on
code quality and the biggest component
of that is an agentic flow that they
have specifically to help you write
tests for your code and that my friend
is something that is overlooked by way
too many people they also just released
Coden 1.0 an AI coder that leverages mCP
way more than I've ever seen before and
mCP is a big deal right now so I love
seeing Cotto just leaning into that and
if you don't know mCP is anthropics
model context protocol it gives AI
access to specialized tools to
understand your codebase and do things
within it that it couldn't do before so
Cotto can be installed directly as a
plugin in your IDE like VSS code or jet
brain so I'm in vs code here you just go
to the extensions tab search for Cotto
and then click on install it is that
easy to get started then you'll have
this Cotto chat in the Le hand side so
you have two modes you have the agentic
mode that's the new Coten 1.0 it's going
to have a very similar feel to something
like Windsor for cursor
except all of it is driven by these mCP
tools you can add custom ones yourself
and then you have the standard mode this
is where you can do things like go
through the testing agentic flow to
write tests for your code and that's
what we're going to do right now I'm
going to show you what this looks like
because it is just so cool so I have
this simple python script right here and
then to write some tests I'll show you
this conversation that I went through
with it so you can see what this looks
like so first you tell it that you want
to write test with SL test and then it
goes through these questions to help
understand the framework you want to use
and the different testing scenarios that
you want to cover with your unit tests
and then once you do that and you can
add custom ones as well it'll create all
of those tests and so this is the file
that it spit out for me with pest
covering all those different scenarios
that we walk through in the conversation
together it is just so powerful whether
you're writing new code fixing bugs
implementing new features from tickets
or building front end components codo
Jen 1.0 can do it all and help you do it
with high code quality so I'll have
links in the description of this video
for you to check out code gen 1.0
install it for free right now in your
idees like Jet prain and VSS code it's
definitely worth a shot now for version
three we're going to add a tool to our
travel agent tools are how AI agents are
given the ability to interact with the
outside world to do things like search
for flights Reserve hotels or get
weather information and in our case
that's the tool we're going to add here
is a weather tool because we want our
agent as it's planning the trip to have
weather data because that'll probably
dictate the activities that it
recommends and so to add tools with the
open AI SDK it is super simple first we
have to define a function and this is
going to be what we give to our agent
for it to be able to get weather data
and so this at function tool decorator
this tells the agent SDK that it is a
tool for an agent and then we can Define
it just as a regular python function the
important thing to note here is that the
parameters that we give to this tool
this is determined by the large language
model So based on the conversation it's
going to pick the city and the date pass
those into this get weather forecast to
get the result get the weather data and
then we also have this dock string this
comment at the top of the function this
is given as a part of the prompt to the
llm to tell it when and how to use this
tool so it's very important to get this
right be very descriptive here
especially if the way that you want the
agent to use the tool might be unique or
be different depending on the state of
the conversation so you describe it all
in the dock string and then in this case
we're just using mock data for
demonstration purposes but for a real
implementation you definitely want to
use a weather API and so in our case to
keep it simple we're just checking to
see if the city that the llm is
requesting weather data for exists in
this dictionary if it does then we're
going to get again more fake data here
and just return this string to the llm
and then if the city does not exist in
that dictionary we'll just say that the
weather forecast is not available and so
the important thing to keep in mind for
tools is that the llm determines the
parameters and then whatever string we
return is given back to the llm so it
then reasons about the result of calling
that tool like now it has the weather
data to help it plan its trip and then
it'll format that final response using
what it got back from the tool to help
it do so and then to add the tool into
our SDK agent it is very simple we just
add this line right here so we give it a
list of tools which in this case is a
single tool we're only giving it one
right now to get the weather forecast
and it is that simple so now I can go
back over to my terminal and run version
three this time I got a couple of test
queries just like with version two this
time it'll look similar but it will
include the weather data so look at this
in Miami we're expecting sunny weather
with temperatures around 25 to 35 C and
if I look at my fake data that is
correct it fetched the right information
for Miami it's not just making that up
and then if we go to uh yeah looks like
we have Paris for our second query
temperatures of 12 to 22 and there we go
Yep this is working perfect now for
version 4 let's add in some other agents
and Implement agent handoffs so here's
the thing we want to include the ability
to get flight information and hotel
information for our travel planner
assistant as well and we could just dump
in more tools to get flight and hotel
data into our primary agent but it gets
to a certain point no matter how large
of a context window an agent can handle
it will start to hallucinate the more
tools you add into the agent so it
always helps to have multiple
specialized agents working together
otherwise known as mixture of experts
and so that's what we're going to add in
here we're going to add in an agent that
is dedicated to handling flights and
another that is dedicated to handling
hotels and then our primary travel agent
can call upon those specialized agents
when the user is asking about something
like a flight or booking a hotel and so
what we see right here is the exact same
as version 3 right now but we're going
to add in a couple of Agents starting
with our flight agent and so we have a
another model because we're going to use
structured outputs for the other
specialized agents as well this one will
recommend flights and so it has
information like the airline when it
departs the arrival time everything that
a user would care about when they are
looking at different flight options and
then we'll Define our tool so this agent
is going to have a tool to search for
flights and we Define it in exactly the
same way as our weather tool with again
a dock string that tells our flight
agent when and how to use this tool with
the parameters of the origin destination
and the date of the flight and again
just using mock data here you'd want to
use some sort of real flight search API
but I'm just going to mock this data and
return it to the llm so it can take in
this information and then pick one of
these flights or multiple of these
flights to recommend based on what the
user is saying in the conversation and
what their preferences are and so with
the tool and the model defined we can
now Define our agent and so we're giving
the name of flight specialist list and
then the handoff description this is a
new attribute this is given to our
primary travel agent as a description of
when to call upon this agent so it's a
specialist specifically for finding and
recommending flights and then we have
our instructions like before of course
fine tune to our flight agent our model
it has the tool to search for flights
and then our output type is again this
model right here so that we know that
every time it outputs a response we have
these attributes to report back to to
the user so that is our flight agent
then we want to Define our hotel agent
so again another class we want to know
the hotel name location price amenities
and then even giving a justification for
why it is recommending this hotel and
then we have another tool to search for
hotels quite a few parameters here but
we even have the ability to search based
on a Max price so there's a lot going on
here the agent is able to use this as a
robust tool to search for hotels in a
specific City for a specific date and
within a specific price range it's
pretty neat so mock data again a lot of
information for each Hotel we're going
to filter by a Max price if applicable
otherwise just give us all of the hotel
options and return those to our hotel
agent which Speaking of that we'll
Define it right here so again handoff
instruction this is a specialized agent
not for flights this time for hotels
finding and recommending hotels got our
instructions Model Search tool and then
that class so that every time it up puts
a response we get all the information
for its recommended Hotel including the
justification for it it's pretty neat
and so that's everything for setting up
the agents now to get these handoffs
configured we have to go to our original
travel agent that's kind of the primary
agent driving this conversation the only
thing we have to add is this line so
handoffs just like tools is an array but
this time instead of tools it can call
it's other agents it can call upon if it
wants to hand off the conversation to
the flight agent or the hotel agent it
is that easy it's so simple this kind of
thing setting it up with something like
Lang chain would be a lot more
complicated to get these handoffs
configured and that's everything so now
I'll go back to my terminal I'll do
python version 4 got some test queries
just like we saw earlier and so this
time instead of saying I want to plan an
entire trip I'm going to get more
specific I need a flight from New York
to Chicago and there we go it handed off
to the flight agent which outputs these
pieces of information instead of the
more higher level here's the budget
here's the activities I recommend all
that good stuff and so it's recommending
an Ocean Air flight and then find me a
hotel in Paris with a pool for under
$300 per night there we go that fits our
budget it has a pool so it's got the
good amenities it handed it over to the
hotel agent to find this information so
cool I just love how these agents work
together uh you really want that
specialization when it comes to
including more than just a couple of
tools for your agent so this is just a
really good example of that now for
version five I want to show you how to
implement guard rails context and
tracing a lot going on here that I want
to show you because the open AI SDK just
gives us a lot and so for a guardrail
what we want to do here is we want to
have a pre-check before the agent starts
planning the trip to see if it's even
realistic given the duration and the
budget that the user has because if we
let the agent plan a trip no matter what
the user says we'll probably run into
some hallucinations cuz if they want to
go to Dubai for only $300 for a week
obviously that can't happen so we don't
even want the agent to try to plan that
trip so let's add that guardrail right
here so it's going to be another agent
just like all our other guys that we
have for Budget analysis so it's
structured output it's going to tell us
is the budget realistic what's the
reasoning for that and a suggested
budget as well so then we'll Define our
budget analysis agent giving it
instructions for how to determine if the
budget is really realistic so we're
leaving it up to the llm to make that
determination which I think is fine
especially for this demo case that we
have then we pass in that budget
analysis class and then we have a
function to define the budget guard rail
this is the function that we're going to
give as the guard rail to our primary
travel agent and so what we're going to
do is prompt the budget analysis agent
so we give it the latest user message
which that's them saying I want to go to
Dubai for $300 and then we're just
telling it to analyze and see if the
budget is realistic and so we'll prompt
our budget analysis agent with runner.
run get the final output and then if it
is not a realistic budget we're going to
print that to the terminal and give the
reasoning as well and then regardless
we're going to return the guardrail
function output and this trip wire
triggered if this is true it means that
the budget was not realistic and what
it's going to do is cut the execution
short so this budget guardrail will run
in parallel with our travel agent as
it's starting to plan the trip but it's
going to get cut short if it figures out
that the budget is not realistic and
then we'll just say that it's a false
for the trip wire triggered if there's
any exception that is encountered when
it's trying to evaluate the budget and
that is it and then for our travel agent
the way that we add this in is we just
add this new input guard rails parameter
and then we pass in the budget guard
rail for our input guard rail you can do
output guard rails as well if you want
to evaluate before you send to the user
but after the agent finishes you can do
either both are very powerful in this
case we want to evaluate before the
agent even gets a chance to fully plan
the trip cuz what's the point of
planning it if it's not realistic in the
first place and that is it so now I'm
going to open my terminal again let me
clear this and start it from scratch
python version 5 we're going to start
with a few queries that should not trip
this guardrail at all like going to
Miami for 5 days with a budget of 2000
yeah it's pretty realistic and we can
see that it did not trip the guardrail
we got our final response and it's going
to be like that for all of these except
for the very last one at the bottom that
I'll show you so it's going to be let me
go to the query here it's going to say I
want to go to Dubai for a week with only
$300 obviously that can't happen so look
at this I want to go to Dubai for a week
with only $300 but boom look at this
your budget for your trip may not be
realistic and then it gives its
reasoning and we get that warning at the
end here that the guard rail was
triggered so this is working great and
this is the kind of thing that I don't
see in Frameworks enough I don't see
guard rails a lot and so I just love
that the open AI agent SDK has included
this I want to show you the context
management as well now cuz that's going
to lead into the streamlit user
interface where we can set our
preferences and so I have this data
class defined for user context these are
pieces of information that our tools are
going to have access to that aren't
actually given as a part of the prompt
to the llm and so the reason we want
that is sometimes we need higher level
metadata to use in our tools something
like a user ID or preferred Airlines we
don't necessarily need to give as a part
of the prompt to the llm and so we
Define this class and then if I go all
the way down to the main function in
version five right here we Define the
user context and right now I just have
these values hardcoded but in our
streamlet UI we'll be able to set these
with that sidebar on the left side so we
give our preferred Airlines Hotel
amenities budget level all that is
defined is an instance of this user
context class and then when we call our
runner. run before we just passed in the
agent and the user's message but now we
give this third parameter which is the
user context and when you do this it's
not given to the llm I want to to make
that very clear and they make it very
clear in their documentation but when we
call a tool like let me go up to uh
let's go up to the flight tool for
example so I'll go up to uh search
flights we have this extra parameter at
the start which is the user context in
this variable called wrapper and so now
at the bottom of this function before we
just return all the flight options but
this time we are sorting the flight
options based on the preferred Airlines
if those exist and so you can see how
you can take this metadata about the
user their name their ID their
preferences whatever and you can alter
these functions and how they operate
based on that information it's super
important and so the recommended hotels
and flights are going to change based on
what we said are our preferences and
then even in the main function below
right here we'll say hey this matches
your preferred amenities or for the
flight will say hey this matches your
preferred Airline so we can really
personalize the communication to the
user letting them know like yeah I heard
what you said and here you go this is
the flight that matches what you were
looking for it's pretty powerful so the
very last feature that I want to cover
is tracing so I have their documentation
page for it pulled up right here if you
are using their default tracing
functionality it's going to be using the
trace dashboard in the open aai platform
but if you're not using open AI models
or if you just want to set up custom
tracing which I'd recommend they have
some Integrations that you can see if
you scroll to the bottom of this page my
favorite is pantic logfire it is super
easy to set up and you get 10 million
traces per month for free so pretty much
free I'd highly recommend this
especially if you're using like open
router or AMA you won't have access to
those traces in the open aai dashboard
obviously and so going to their
documentation don't ask me how they got
this integration set up already with the
open AI agent SDK but they did with just
a couple lines of code so you can just
go to the getting started here go
through getting your log fire API key
and setting that up and then in my code
you can see that I import log fire and
then with just these two lines of code I
set this for my configuration for all of
my tracing and there's nothing else I
have to do in my code so go ahead and
check this out it's so cool so I'll go
to my streamlet UI like I promised I'd
showcase again set my preferences on the
left hand side like we just saw how to
do with version five and then um I can
save my preferences start a new
conversation and say something like I
want to go to Tokyo for a week for uh
let's just say $3,000 all right and we
get this beautiful UI now we don't have
to use that command line anymore we'll
get a response that looks super nice and
then we can go to our log fire dashboard
this is my execution that just happened
now so I can expand into this to see the
different agents that were called I can
even look into my guard rail as well and
see that the triggered is false it used
my budget analyzer agent with gbt 40
mini and then I got my final response
with gbt 40 mini I want to go to Tokyo
for a week for $3,000 and then this is
the structured output that we got this
Json that my front end then transformed
into this beautiful component so this is
working really well and just overall it
was so easy to create this really
indepth travel planning agent with the
agent SDK so I hope this was a really
good starting point for you for using
the open aai Agent SDK I wanted to cover
all of those features so that no matter
what you were building you can take out
the different components from what I
built to use for your own use case but
now I want to cover the big question is
worth using the open aai Agent SDK and
this is of course Up For Debate so I'd
love to hear in the comments what you
think as well but I just want to give
you my two cents really quick so my
favorite Frameworks up until this point
have been pantic Ai and L graph I've
covered them on my channel a lot and the
reason I like them so much besides they
just work really well together is that
they are a lowlevel abstraction and what
I mean by that is they don't try to do
too much for you so you have to write
more code but then you get that full
control and customiz AB ility that I
really want when I'm building my agents
there are other Frameworks like Lang
chain and crew aai that try to do too
much for you in my mind it's what's
called an abstraction distraction it's
really easy to use those Frameworks
because they take care of so much for
you but then in the end you don't really
understand what's going on behind the
scenes and it's hard to customize it to
your needs and really have that control
and for the agent SDK I find it leads a
bit more towards that crew Ai and Lang
chain level of abstraction and so it's
very easy to use as we saw it's pretty
powerful I do like it more than crew aai
and Lang chain but like let's go to the
handoffs for example it was so easy to
set up handoffs like we saw in our code
like you can see in this example but
what if I want to handoff to multiple
agents or if I want custom rules in
place before a handoff takes place or
maybe after a handoff takes place I
don't really see how I can do all of
that and I'm sure I'm missing some
things like maybe specifically it's easy
to have something run before a handoff
but I just don't see it here for
everything and another big thing that
the agent SDK is missing is human in the
loop and that's something that L graph
does so well being able to before you
call a specific tool or execute a
specific agent actually seek approval
from the human through the command line
or a user interface or whatever before
that action is taken and I don't really
see how to do that like how would you
have a human approve an agent handoff I
don't think that's possible in the frame
work here and another thing that pantic
AI focuses on a lot that they don't do
here is testing having a mock llm or
mock tools being able to really validate
that your agents are working well
without using a real llm and if you go
to the pantic AI documentation I won't
show it here but they cover that in such
great detail that you don't see anything
for testing your agents or evaluating
your agents in this documentation like
you do for pantic AI so I don't think
this is mature yet compared to pidan Ai
and L graph but it is brand new so maybe
they'll do more over time but in general
I just think that it's missing some key
things I didn't feel like I had that
level of control and customizability
that I really would want for those full
production applications that I want to
be building with my AI agents and going
back to the code here I thought it was
really nice coding with this framework I
I enjoyed it I found it fun I felt like
I built something that was pretty neat
with just a few hours of prep for this
video was pretty good but I don't feel
like I could extend this to that full
travel agent I maybe want to build I
would probably rather use pantic AI or L
graph so just my two cents but again
very curious what you think as well so
let me know in the comments what you
think of the open aai Agent SDK
personally I think it's awesome how
simple it is to use to build these
agentic systems but I still don't really
have that level of customizability and
control that I want that I get with some
of these other Frameworks but also this
framework is brand spanking new and so
I'm going to be following it closely
because I'm sure they're going to be
adding in a lot more features over the
upcoming months and so I'm still going
to be using pantic Ai and Lan graph but
watching this closely I think it could
be a big deal so if you appreciated this
content you're looking forward to more
things AI agents I would really
appreciate a like and a subscribe and
with that I will see you in the next
video